[Music]
welcome back Frank hey everybody this is
gonna be my Punisher Easter eggs and
references is probably one of the most
self contained of the Marvel series but
there's still obviously a lot of comic
book references and references to the
other stuff that's been going on so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet but if you are finding me for the
first time we do Marvel every week so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
because we have crazy infinity war stuff
coming up starting with my crows welcome
back Frank probably one of the most
notable Punisher phrases but also a
direct reference to the Garth eNOS comic
book when he's in that pre-credit
sequence in episode one that sort of the
period in between daredevil season 2 and
defenders so like if you wondered why
Punisher wasn't around during defenders
is because he was taking down the new
cheek crime family so the funny thing
about that is that they're part of the
main antagonist from the Welcome Back
frank storyline he mows through their
entire organization from top to bottom
before he comes back to start swinging
that hammer Thor style one of the
biggest ones and one of the biggest
changes was the jigsaw character so
Billy Russo becomes jigsaw in the comics
heat like the way he actually transforms
into jigsaw is the same like the
carousel Fiat when Punisher scrapes his
face across that plate-glass that's how
he became jigsaw in the comics so even
though they did the strangers on a train
Hitchcock thing at the very end and it's
very different from his comic book
persona the way he became jigsaw is the
same so very clearly they'll set him up
to be one of the antagonists if Punisher
gets a season two we won't find out
about that for a little while though but
what I'm hoping is is because jigsaw
goes to work for the mob after he
becomes jigsaw in the comics I'm hoping
he just goes to work for the kingpin and
they can just tie him in with that the
fake identity that he's assumed in the
first episode while he's working on that
construction site Pete Castiglione is
obviously a reference to castle it's
just like the italianized
version of castle because in the comics
his family comes from Sicily so just
sort of paying reference to that we
learn about his military history in
Afghanistan during episode three that's
obviously the newer version of his
Vietnam vet status in the comics they
did that a little
during daredevil season 2 the really
cool spider-man Easter Egg is actually
that he's localized to Queens so each of
the Marvel Netflix heroes is sort of
localized to their own borough like
you're either in Hell's Kitchen or
you're up at Harlem like Luke Cage or
you're in Midtown like Danny ran
Punisher is in Queens because he started
out as a spider-man character so it's
just a big wink at all of that stuff
so obviously Punisher is just so
different from the tone of spider-man in
the movies right now that I would be
just blown away I would fall out of my
chair if we ever saw a Tom Holland on
the Netflix series but it just feels
like it's way too hardcore for his
character to show up there are a couple
links to the other versions of The
Punisher that we've seen so far like
Thomas Jane makes his punisher shirt by
spray-painting the logo on they have a
similar scene like that with Frank doing
his body armor again there are a number
of books that he reads which are all
kind of metaphors for what's going on in
the story so Moby Dick very seminal
story the white whale that he's going
after is the Rawlins character it's just
that he doesn't find out who that is
till later in the series there's a crack
up by f scott Fitzgerald they're cyborgs
and Barbie dolls feminism popular
culture in the posthuman body and then
it's a little on the nose but in the
flashbacks jigsaw is reading the Picture
of Dorian Gray throughout that story the
character gains his immortality then
just proceeds to destroy the lives of
everyone around him for his own personal
gain while at the same time the Picture
of Dorian Gray continues to manifest the
evil within Dorian Gray so like the
picture becomes a mirror for his evil
just becoming more and more grizzled but
at the end of the series they have that
visual imagery of him with all the
cut-up cheeks and Frank making him stare
into the mirror so it's like he's
actually staring at his own portrait so
the entire jigsaw story is sort of the
Picture of Dorian Gray
when Lewis is watching rumble in the
jungle with his father in the television
that Muhammad Ali fight that's from 1974
that's also the same year that the
punisher debuted in the comics remember
it's amazing spider-man number 129
because originally he started out as
something of a spider-man villain during
that opening credits sequence the bikers
that he runs down with the van which is
also sort of a nod to the Punisher van
the actual Punisher van he doesn't get
till later in the series
but like this at the end he's actually
driving around in legit comic book
punisher van the bikers that he runs
down at the beginning are actually from
that gang that he tried to take down
during daredevil season 2 'the speaking
of daredevil turk shows up in some
comedic relief very brief scene but he's
a weapons dealer so it makes sense that
frank would go to him looking for
weapons they only find a pink gun which
is pretty hilarious
there's a news headline inside Karen's
office that reads chaos under the
streets which is a reference to
everything that happened during
defenders just reminding you about where
this takes place but they kind of handle
that with a pre credit sequence in the
first time he meets Karen so if you're
wondering where daredevil is right now
while this is all happening they still
believe that he's dead he's still being
taken care of by these nuns they'll pick
up with that during daredevil season 3
which is also probably where Punisher
will show back up because he said see
you around red so that's probably a wink
to him coming back during daredevil they
brought back that news station wh IH
that we saw viral teasers for back
during Avengers age of Ultron we saw it
during agents of shield I think we also
saw during Captain America Civil War
they use it as sort of like their CNN
fox news that goes after the Avengers
and the Marvel characters even though
they're doing good things this is pretty
crazy but one of the villains that he
takes down during the series he knocks
onto a pinball machine that's actually a
direct reference to a spider-man toy
that they sold a long time ago you could
actually buy this once upon a time but
otherwise they weave in a lot of other
movie references they make a lot of
jokes about Thor's hammer when he's
hammering those walls obviously it's
just him working through his grief micro
obviously big comic book characters this
version is very different but he's
always been Franks man in the chair
there have been Punisher titles where
micro has been the villain so they've
actually fought each other maybe they'll
address that in a future season but they
kind of do that during the course of
this series where they're butting heads
like because Frank doesn't want to have
anything to do with him for a while then
they come together before he learns
Rollins name they only call him Agent
Orange that's his code name agent orange
is obviously a very deadly bioweapon
used during the Vietnam War which is
this another reference to comic book
Frank but aside from Spider Man and Thor
there aren't too many Marvel movie
references and there aren't that many
references to the other Marvel Netflix
series either it's one of the most
self-contained series but they do
reference stuff that happened during
defenders so there is some continuity
but I think that's really just because
of the subject matter in the tone of the
stuff that they're dealing with they
want to deal with Frank's grief so I
think one of the biggest criticisms is
that one it didn't need to be 13
episodes they probably could have done
this in eight episodes and it can get
really depressing so people either
really love this because they love the
Punisher
or they hate it because it makes them
feel so terrible about themselves like
Punisher is a bit of an emotional
investment you have to be prepared
before you watch some of these episodes
so there are any big Marvel Easter eggs
that you guys spotted that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments and let me know
what you thought of the series but all
in all I thought that Jon Bernthal did
an amazing performance although I don't
think that we need another Punisher
series right away maybe in a couple
years but I do want to see him come back
during daredevil season 3 and I do want
to see jigsaw working for the kingpin at
some point because I am 99% sure that
the kingpin will become the big bad for
the next defenders team-up but there is
still a movie ticket giveaway going on
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video obviously there's an infinity war
trailer that's coming in the next couple
of weeks or so there have been rumors
that the date has been confirmed but we
can talk about that the next time I post
an infinity war video next up some big
Justice League bombs just dropped they
started releasing actual post-credit
scene stuff and talking about the
deleted post credits so that video will
post in a little while but you can click
here for that funny ant-man infinity war
teaser and you can click here for the
trailer for the big DC TV crossover
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you